ginsburg's death is sure to set off
another partisan battle during an
already highly contentious election year
here to discuss what this vacancy on the
supreme court will mean is cbs news
white house correspondent paula reed
she's at the supreme court
and cbs news political correspondent ed
o'keefe
paula let's start with you and we just
heard nicole mention some of this at the
end of her report
will president trump nominate a
successor to ruth bader ginsburg
well good morning dana sources tell me
the president will absolutely
nominate a replacement and do everything
in his power
to push that person through even if he
is not elected
to a second term just last week the
president released
names of possible people he would
consider for any supreme court vacancy
the list included judges he's already
appointed to the federal bench
including senators like also included
senators
like ted cruz and tom cotton now the
president hoped that this list
would galvanize his conservative
supporters because back in 2016
following the death of justice antonin
scalia
candidate trump released a similar list
and that list prompted a lot of
conservatives particularly evangelical
christians
to give him another look and ultimately
helped propel him to the white house
the president has said aside from issues
of war and peace
this is the most important decision an
american president can make
so far paul it seems like some are
framing the election as a referendum on
covet and the president's facing of
covet 19. how do you see this impacting
the election now
it will be significant because the
majority of voters say that the supreme
court is an important factor
in how they vote and this comes at a
tumultuous time for president trump
his handling of the kovit pandemic is
not seen favorably by the majority
of voters as you noted the biden
campaign is trying to frame this as a
referendum on his handling
of kovid and this gives the trump
campaign a chance to reframe this
election
as a referendum on the supreme court and
for president trump that's good news
that's an
opportunity for him to potentially
galvanize independent voters
women and those voters who don't like
him or his twitter accounts
he's also out ahead of his opponent
because he's already released this list
now the biden campaign joe biden has
said that he would like to nominate a
black woman to the supreme court
but he has not released a list of names
the campaign says they're working on it
but voters do not have that information
at this point all right let's turn ahead
now ed
what can we expect to hear from both the
trump and biden campaigns as far as
messaging
goes is this is this going to be the
dominant message
for the next 45 days here certainly will
be for the republicans jeff look the
trump campaign message right now or the
slogan one of them
promises made promises kept the biggest
promise he's arguably made to his base
of support
conservative voters is not only putting
two supreme court justices
on the bench but also hundreds of judges
on district and appeals courts across
the country record-setting numbers they
have essentially cleared the vacancy
list
four years ago one in five voters went
to the polls and told us on election day
they were there because of the supreme
court this was in the final days of the
2016 campaign
the reason that the republican coalition
coalesce behind donald trump because
or despite the concerns they might have
had about him they have been running
that playbook again this year vice
president pence especially has been
traveling the country telling
evangelicals and conservative audiences
don't forget you elect joe biden you're
going to get liberal justices on the
court you keep us in place you'll get
more conservative justices
well now that message just gets
amplified joe biden however
turns around and says makes an argument
that was made four years ago
the voters should pick a president and
that president should elect a successor
to justice ginsburg
arguing that let this election go
through then let's start the
nomination and confirmation process but
republicans will turn right around and
say
we did elect a president we elected him
four years ago
and donald trump is ready to put on a
successor ed as paula mentioned joe
biden has not released a potential list
of nominees
why not and and will he now
so i was the one that asked him about
this back in late june i said look the
president has this list he put it out
four years ago
would you do the same thing there have
been liberal organizations pushing him
to do so arguing
that just as it's an issue for the right
it should be a galvanizing issue on the
left but biden told me
one thing i hesitate to do is follow
anything this president does
because he does it all wrong but he said
i will at some point release a list of
the black women that i would consider
nominating to the supreme court
after they're fully vetted last week
when that list was released by the
president again we asked the biden
campaign how's the vetting going where's
the list
we heard nothing they are likely now to
face renewed pressure
to come up with that list put it forth
and give voters a sense
of who these black women are that he
would consider to put on the court it's
certainly a subject of debate
paula now how will this process play out
on capitol hill
well michelle buckle up last night
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
confirmed that the president's nominee
will get a vote on the floor but
typically supreme court nominees take
months for a confirmation so it's
unlikely this will happen before the
election
but there will be time during a lame
duck session after
the election to push this through now of
course mitch mcconnell famously denied
former president barack obama
his nominee merrick garland but going
forward it's expected that mcconnell
will try to use
this vacancy to galvanize supporters in
november
arguing that they need momentum behind
this nominee even for the lame duck
session
it's important to note though right
before her death a former
justice ginsburg dictated this statement
to her granddaughter saying that her
most fervent wish
is that i will not be replaced until a
new president installed
is installed it appears that the wheels
are in motion for that wish
not to be granted oh paula reed
at o'keefe we thank you this morning for
being here